This just in: Spider-Man is set to swing back
into cinemas for an extra-special re-release.
Sony Pictures announced on August 19th that
Spider-Man: Far From Home will return to theaters
over Labor Day weekend.
Here's what you need to know about the re-release.
First and most importantly is the launch date.
According to Variety, Spider-Man: Far From
Home's re-release run will begin on Thursday,
August 29th.
It's not clear how long Far From Home will
stick around in cinemas for its second outing,
though it appears that it may be a one-weekend-only
engagement.
Spidey fans would be wise to clear their schedules
from Thursday to Sunday just to be safe.
Sony has confirmed that those in the U.S.
and Canada will be able to attend the Spider-Man:
Far From Home re-release in standard-format
showings as well as in IMAX and large-format
screenings, available at select locations.
Viewers might want to spend a little extra
money on an IMAX ticket for the re-release
of Spider-Man: Far From Home because it will
be an extended cut of the theatrical version
of the film.
Sony has included four minutes of additional
footage not shown in the original cut of Far
From Home.
The studio is keeping quiet about what this
extra footage entails, but we have a few ideas
regarding what it might be.
The four minutes reportedly make up a single
scene, with Collider's Steve Weintraub speculating
that this sequence will take place ahead of
the main action of Spider-Man: Far From Home.
Weintraub has good reason to suspect that,
after speaking with the director of Far From
Home, Jon Watts, in a recent interview in
which Watts opened up about the scenes left
out of the theatrical cut of the movie.
Watts explained that one deleted scene involves
Tom Holland's Peter Parker running around
New York and completing errands before jetting
off to Europe:
"There's just this very simple thing where
we had Peter doing errands, getting ready
for his trip.
And it's going back to Mr. Delmar's, the deli,
that's been rebuilt since it was blown up
in Homecoming.
And he has this very Spider-Man list of things
to do.
It's like get his passport, get the dual head
phone adapter so he can listen to music with
MJ on a flight, take down a giant gang."
He added that the Far From Home team put that
scene together as a kind of short film.
Based on the intel Watts offered in his sit-down
with Weintraub, it seems there's a solid chance
that the four minutes of extra footage included
in the Spider-Man: Far From Home re-release
could be that little short film.
"Keep up the good work, because I am going
on vacation."
The one question that remains after learning
all there is to know about the Spider-Man:
Far From Home re-release is why Sony is doing
it in the first place.
While it's tough to say with complete certainty,
it appears that those at Sony are taking a
page out of Marvel's playbook with the Far
From Home re-release and may be looking to
push the film into an even higher tier of
financial success.
Earlier this year, Marvel Studios gave Avengers:
Endgame a re-release that helped the film
beat out James Cameron's Avatar to become
the best-earning movie of all time.
Far From Home, on the other hand, recently
became Sony's most profitable movie ever,
edging out Skyfall after grossing $1.109 billion
at the global box office.
Far From Home is sitting atop $376 million
at the domestic box office, so it's plausible
that Sony is aiming to send Far From Home
past the $400 million domestic benchmark with
the upcoming re-release.
In any case, the Spider-Man: Far From Home
re-release is worth getting excited about.
It may not feature much extra footage, but
any time spent with the friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man is time well spent.
"You're that spider-guy from YouTube, right?"
"Call me Spider-Man."
"Okay, Spider-Man, do a flip."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.